[Music]
but the past I assumed I'd become
mentally
darkness rises at night to meet
I need someone
to show me my place in all this
come on
[Music]
this is not going to go away you think
everybody's surprised new Star Wars
World Series trailer let's break it down
with a whole bunch of new shots Luke
Skywalker on the Falcon so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's Star
Wars tickets I'm giving away I'll
explain at the end of the video too so I
like the way they have that Snoke voice
over where he says darkness rises in the
light to meet it making it sound like
everything is getting turned up like it
becomes a metaphor for kylo Ren versus
Rey even though I think that's a bit of
a misdirection but he's all about
creating this new type of Jedi and I
think in order to bring that about he
needs to have a Rea rise to the occasion
along with kylo Ren so he's sort of
engineering what seems like a match
between them in Luke Skywalker's off on
the side too knowing that the Jedi Order
needs to change in some fundamental way
so it just sounds like they're hyping up
them building towards some giant huge
epic reveal and most people are talking
about Rey's backstory and who her
parents are in how that's gonna be
really meaningful for the characters in
a really cool touching moment for the
saga but I'll be interested to see how
this lines up with the Journal of the
Wills in these new ideas about the force
that Snoke is trying to push on everyone
but it is just so nuts seeing Luke
Skywalker back on the bridge of the
Falcon like he's looking around just
like not sure what to think about
everything I think he's just filled with
so much trepidation from the moment he
sees his father's lightsaber
he's just weary of everything like he's
totally afraid of how this is gonna blow
up in their faces it went sideways with
kylo Ren he remembers the destruction to
the last temple how he has that line of
dialogue this isn't going to go the way
you'd think it's going to go and you see
Rey like in sort of the corresponding
shot raising the lightsaber looking like
she's rising to the occasion the way
they cut it with snoke's dialogue you
get a much better shot of him on his
throne there too and I love the way his
voice isn't quite as processed as we've
heard it before the last time we saw him
in force awakens he was a hologram so
his voice sounded like it was being
processed through a voice box so even
though he looks really twisted by the
force he doesn't sound quite as evil as
Palpatine sounded people after the
original trilogy really did use him is
sort of the archetypal look for old
angry evil Wiz
so there's just a couple more shots of
that space battle with the resistance I
think that happens relatively early in
the film but also a lot of the Falcon on
crates so obviously that corresponds
with them flying through the salt mines
here whatever it is these are maybe they
used to be underwater millions of years
ago we've seen corresponding shots of
leia with these crystal foxes here that
are native to the planet they just look
so cool so this shot of fin driving what
looks like one of these vehicles that
are charging the gorilla walkers all
looks like it's happening maybe in like
the third act of the film this feels
like it's happening much later but I
know a lot of you are wondering if Mark
Hamill actually ever got any scenes with
Carrie Fisher and I believe they did I
don't know what their scenes were but
most of the stuff that we've seen from
Leia has been on the bridge of her ship
and down on this crate planet and this
is the first footage we've seen up Luke
that implies that he actually does go
somewhere even though I think we all
knew it like he's holding the lightsaber
in that new Japanese poster they said
that even though Luke Skywalker is sort
of an obi-wan Kenobi type person he's
the mentor in this movie he's gonna get
a lot more fun things to do than obi-wan
did during a new hope obi-wan still got
the throw down but imagine much more
badass versions of that this little ones
not worth it don't let me get you
something
[Applause]
[Music]
Loup will actually get to be as badass
as you hoped he would be when you
originally heard that they were going to
be making more movies that felt like it
was an early complaint when it was like
oh you know what's Luke Skywalker doing
oh he's hiding out on a planet is he
gonna do anything we don't know yes he
will definitely be throwing down but it
sounds like it takes him a while to spin
up on that idea like he's really
hesitant about going off with Rey this
isn't going to go the way you think it's
going to go but everybody let me know
what you think of this I can't imagine
how much Lucasfilm paid to advertise
this during the world series but I'm
happy that they did I totally wasn't
expecting it like I saw it pop on
Twitter and all of a sudden it started
playing and sure enough Millennium
Falcon with Luke just looking around
like this crazy old man oh my god what
am I doing here
most of the stuff we've been talking
about has been very Snoke in Rey centric
a little bit of Luke Skywalker but for
all of you who are disappointed in kylo
Ren during force awakens it sounds like
based on what Adam driver and the other
people around the movie had been saying
that they actually do provide a lot of
context and it won't be quite where
you're expecting given the twists of
force awakens like it really does sound
like he's on a redemptive arc even
though coming back from killing han Solo
sounds like it could be impossible one
of the most beloved characters in the
Star Wars universe
so that's kind of why I think that he
might fail at the task of killing his
mother because they've been very coy
about how her story ends they said it's
very meaningful and she's very important
to this movie but it does sound like
Snoke gets very frustrated with kylo Ren
because he still feels the pull of the
light and that will inform a lot of the
direction of episode 9 like darkness is
rising inside kylo Ren but the light
inside him is also rising to meet it so
it's a metaphor for kylo Ren and Rey
separately but it's also more of an
internal metaphor for what's going on
inside the minds of kylo Ren and Rey
so like separately they seem like dark
and light but within them they both
harbor dark and light so everybody let
me know what you think what's going on
with the characters there is a new round
of that Star Wars take a giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a Star Wars comment
on the video
congratulations to last week's winner
Cody Greene please private message me so
I can get your contact details you can
click here for that other Star Wars
trailer and you can click here for brand
new Titans Nightwing season 1 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight